what I do in my book is rather than say
okay all of these things that people
have been canceled for joking about you
can I take it nine million steps further
and I say there's not a such thing as
something that you can't joke about and
yes I'm including religion yes I'm
including death yes I'm including
terminal illness because there's
research that backs this stuff up I'm
not just saying this
thank you
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the co-host of the number one show in
late night Gutfeld with an exclamation
point as well as author of the new book
you can't joke about that why everything
is funny nothing is sacred and we're all
in this together my friend cat Tim cat
Welcome finally is this their first
appearance this is it first time on the
Reuben report it is
it is actually it's been a long time
coming but yes this is my very first
time I'm very excited to be here
very first time now first off
technically am I is that correct or do
you are you a co-host on Gutfeld I mean
you're in the chair basically every day
and Tyrus is in the other chair and then
there are two other guests but are you
technically did I get that right
yeah no that's right Greg will call me
that so I think it's allowed I told you
right before we started that I'm gonna
treat you like Greg treats you because I
want you to feel at home here is that is
that all right
absolutely
okay very good uh let's get well before
we get into some of the politics stuff
and and the stuff around free speech and
all the stuff that we're normally
talking about uh you go a bit into your
into growing up and and youth and how
that sort of frames some of the beliefs
that you have so you want to do a little
bit of that first
um are you talking about you know when I
started doing stand-up back in you know
when I was growing up when I was 22.
um I was even going back further than
that growing up in a Catholic household
and and some of the Sacred cows there
but we can we can do that too
okay yeah I mean it's like that's the
first chapter and then the Catholic
household is the second chapter
um I can get into either one
um
so for me I mean this is the final
chapter in my book but for me comedy is
a religion for me because I
unfortunately don't have a religion I
say unfortunately because I think I
probably would be I know I would be
happier if I were religious but I just I
can't really seem to get there I hope
that it changes someday for me but
comedy actually does a lot of the same
things as religion does right
um it brings people closer together it
can add meaning to
um certain experiences in your life
including the traumatic ones
um it can you know be healing mentally
it can be healing emotionally and even
physically the Boost that you get from
laughter and your immunity and there's
all these different studies the two
things that it's really missing is first
of all the prom there's no promise of
eternal life with any joke no matter how
good it is unfortunately
and um the second thing that's missing
is forgiveness right because every
religion has some sort of path to
forgiveness
uh the Catholic church was confession
which I would go and always be honest
even when it was on I was old enough
where my sins were a little bit less
comfortable to talk to
um an older strange man about
um but in like you learn you read the
Bible right Leviticus is Old Testament
so it's like not a CH it's not chill
it's in the New Testament comes in and
it's like
supposed to be about forgiveness and
chill and all you know more easy going
Leviticus is extremely fire and
brimstone text but even Leviticus the
standard is eye for an eye
um what we're doing right now with
comedy and speech is actually stricter
and more fire and burnstone than
Leviticus because I don't think anybody
would tell would be able to honestly
tell you the worst thing that they've
ever been through is hearing a joke that
they thought was offensive but there's
more than one if you've watched Jimmy
Kimmel it can be quite grueling
well see but there's more than one
person who would say telling the wrong
joke
actually is the worst thing that they've
been through because they maybe lost
everything or lost millions and millions
of dollars or lost their respect or you
know ability to come and be a human in
the square right the Public Square so I
feel like if the way that we're treating
jokes is stricter than Leviticus we're
doing something wrong what year did you
start doing stand-up
so I started doing it in college I did
it a few times so I graduated college in
2010 and then after that when I left I
um College I moved to LA it was supposed
to be a short-term move and then I was
going to I was going to I had a
fellowship a stipend to live out there I
had an internship at Fox News and then I
had gotten into Columbia journalism
school so I was gonna use my stipend for
housing until it ran out and then live
with my college boyfriend for two weeks
and then we were gonna break up and then
I was gonna go to Columbia and it didn't
work out that way it was I'm 21 so it's
a very dumb plan but where I wasn't dumb
was taking out an 80 000 loan for
journalism School
so I decided instead to just stay in La
get journalism internships and learn
skills for free and wait tables but
things got really rough for a while uh
the boyfriend broke up with me uh I had
to move into this really I was living in
squalor I mean I got fleas and scabies
the same week my cat got the fleas I got
the scabies but then the fleas jumped
onto me that was the same week I lost my
apartment I was running myself ragged I
write up all about it in my first
chapter but what I was doing that made
me feel power in my life was stand-up
comedy every free moment I had I was
going to open mics anywhere I could and
talking about my dumpster fire life on
stage and make you know making jokes
about these things that were making me
feel so helpless gave me some power over
it and hearing people laugh and all of
that and it just makes me
kind of nervous and terrified and upset
about what we're seeing happen in our
culture where you can't joke about sad
or serious or controversial subjects
when really
that that's the way that I found healing
through every tough time in my life was
by joking about the stuff you're not
supposed to joke about do you look back
on them I think I already know the
answer and and think of those years The
Scabies years as the good old days
because I know for me for those 10 years
of struggling in New York City as a
stand-up and standing out in Times
Square with tickets and literally being
broke to the point that I had a friend
who worked in food service and would
deliver me industrial sized cans of tuna
that I would eat for weeks and all of
that stuff I now look back at them kind
of like oh those were the good old days
like I I have everything I want now my
life is good but like there's something
Charming about like that struggle
once you make it to the other side I
guess right exactly it actually is
really strange just how like in what a
specific way I was able to achieve my
goals because back when that guy and I
were still dating in Los Angeles uh his
we were at his brother's house we used
to always watch red eye because it was
on at midnight there and I was like I
would be so good on this show and his
brother was like you're a cashier at
Boston Market which was true like if you
think in terms of what's likely to be
possible I shouldn't have even gotten on
the show let alone been the co-host of
the show that would follow that up but
it is it is remarkable but man those
times were absolutely rough I mean the
treatment for scabies on if you ever had
it you have to cover your entire body in
a cream and just sit there for like
hours on end and the fact that that was
the same time I had to move in with this
Colombian family of this bartender that
I was sort of seeing at my California
Pizza Kitchen job and all these
conversations about how just because I
need to live here doesn't mean we're
together together uh just sitting there
at his house his mom throughout my
Spanish was never better which is I
think like the one positive thing of
that experience I was a very good at
Spanish back then
um but you know like I don't know how I
would have gotten through it if I wasn't
able to laugh at it because if you laugh
at something then you're telling
yourself oh it's not that scary or
telling that thing you're not that scary
and that's the only way I was able to
get through it and now I I just I just
I'm worried that that's not going to be
possible for many people anymore people
are too afraid wait I want to keep going
with that but you worked at Boston
Market and California Pizza Kitchen any
other major chains on your resume
Ruby Tuesday oh and it Ruby Tuesday with
the salad on everything
yes I also worked in a at a diner called
Four and Twenty diners in Sherman Oaks
it was a pipe right it was a pie place
it's supposed to be like 420 blackbirds
baked in a pie but of course everybody a
lot of people would think it was a
restaurant that just made edibles
so I would have to explain to people
like no there's no weed in our food
sorry but I used to live in Sherman Oaks
I don't remember the pie place but that
might have been the Edibles I'm not so
sure yeah does this all like seem very
obvious to you in a way like you know
obviously on the show you guys were
talking about the woke thing constantly
and it just has infected everything
everyone gets it but when you see just
all of these hysterical joyless kids who
are so confused about reality and have
no sense of humor and have gone out of
their way to cancel everybody from the
past and you know go after every show
that we used to love or that friends now
you know Jennifer Aniston says friends
they could never put on air for the
record I'm more of a Seinfeld guy uh but
it just seems like the obvious extension
of this this area doesn't it
yes and see what I do in my book is
rather than say okay all of these things
that people have been canceled for
joking about you can I take it nine
million steps further and I say there's
not a such thing as something that you
can't joke about and yes I'm including
religion yes I'm including death yes I'm
including terminal illness
um because there's research that backs
this stuff up I'm not just saying this I
mean
um I write a chapter obviously about the
bag
um which I had that emergency surgery I
had an ostomy for five weeks and as I
was being wheeled into my surgery I was
like what am I going to tell people
because I know that everybody's gonna be
like oh like so weird around me about it
or scared about what to say same way as
when my mom died at a young age and the
friends I wanted to talk to weren't the
ones with the most carefully chosen
words they were the friends who just
were able to joke around with me about
it I joke around about I threw a cat's
out of the bag party after where I had
some unused but already open ostomy bags
we were buying champagne out of them and
then I started thinking more because I
had a lot of time to do nothing but
think because I had some you know the
ostomy and it was also the pandemic but
think about all the people who have died
recently of cancers we didn't know that
they had like Chadwick Boseman like Norm
Macdonald because they didn't want to be
treated differently they didn't want the
illness to be the defining thing that
people thought about when you talk to
them and you actually I mean I cite this
research in my book there's people that
are terminally ill that people that are
they treat the terminally ill who rank
humor as being super high on their list
even in uh one study that was pretty
small but still higher than the
management of their physical pain
um I when I wrote the chapter I Google
searched cancer and then how to tell
people I have cancer and the second one
had way more results so clearly
everybody kind of gets this but people
are too afraid because of what the
consequences might be if they say the
wrong thing but actually what you're
really doing is the people you're
hurting the most are the ones who the
rules are supposed to be in place to
protect
do you sense that's changing a little
bit I mean even if you were just looking
at the success of Gutfeld I mean it is
by far the number one show in late night
which as you know on the on the debut
episode I predicted that he would be
number one I said it was going to take a
year it took him only about four months
or something which is incredible but I
mean the fact is the one Politically
Incorrect show on late night is the
number one show in late night so that
shows you that something's shifting at
least or maybe it's just exclusive to
you know kind of our side of the aisle
yeah absolutely especially because
there's so much to joke about when it
comes to you know the current
Administration and I think a lot of
other shows are kind of they don't want
to do that
um they I mean our show you can kind of
say stuff that you can definitely not
say on other on other shows it's a very
comfortable place and even for somebody
like me or I'm not a republican
um I'm libertarian very much so and
everybody who watches the show knows
that
um I don't fit into a particular box and
I feel very comfortable on that show
expressing myself even when I do have
opinions that might differ with the you
know typical conservative
um audience and I it's just everything's
cool and I just think
that when we talk about speech and we
talk about comedy a lot of the argument
is okay I can say whatever I want and
you can't stop me no matter how divisive
it might be and that's true but that
also I think really ignores the way that
comedy and open communication can bring
us all together because we're never
going to be able to understand each
other if we can't fully express
ourselves to each other
yeah it's true do you remember when you
first wanted to make people laugh I mean
I remember the exact moment 1983 I was
sitting in my parents living room
watching Bill Cosby himself and this was
way before you know serial rapist Bill
Cosby or at least that we knew of and I
remember thinking this is you know the
chocolate cake thing and I was just like
this is the funniest thing I've ever
seen that's what I how could you not
want to do that
yeah I mean I've always been a performer
but I have an atrocious singing voice
um but I like I I try to get lessons and
the woman called my mother and said I
don't feel right about taking your money
anymore she's never gonna get it but I
would still audition for all the
musicals at the community theater and I
would just get on stage and I would sing
Happy Birthday everyone had you know
vocal coach and all this stuff and these
prepared numbers and I'd look at them
like I'm a star baby like I don't know
what you're thinking like put me on the
show and I would always have these small
you know roles because I actually really
truly can't sing
so I got more in more into comedy and
you know it's also something that I was
bullied a lot as a child and if I could
laugh at it it became so much easier I
mean even to this day I I write a whole
chapter about toxic positivity where
there's this idea now that
if you know if you don't like something
about your body or your face or
something like that just love it instead
of not liking it just love it and then
you'll be super happy and I don't doubt
that that would be true but what if you
can't I don't think it's possible for
anybody to be completely optimistic
about themselves all the time and I
studies back that up too I mean this
idea of body positivity has been around
forever but it's actually nobody's
actually capable of doing it and what I
found is a great replacement is to make
fun of the things that I hate about
myself so if somebody says something to
me about something you know oh like oh
my I have a flat chest like I was
already at brunch joking about how my
bra size is double mastectomy like I
I've already I beat you and I've made
these things less scary by finding them
you know funny you know speaking of
Health stuff we actually have something
in common that I I did not know until
you told me privately I'm actually not
sure if you've talked about it that much
publicly but my audience knows about
seven years ago or so when I first
started getting popular and I was
getting all this hate and I didn't
realize I wasn't dealing with stress
well I developed alopecia and I lost
probably 40 percent of my hair huge
chunks all over my head I went on crazy
experimental medications it was by far
the most depressed I've ever been I
almost quit like I actually had a night
where I was like I'm not going to be on
camera anymore I'm done I'll just go do
something else but you got that too uh
not not too long ago but I have to say
your hair is looking quite luxurious at
the moment and I have extensions in but
my natural hair is even like down to
here now nice nice and when my you know
mid-20s I lost about a similar amount it
was so thin it was really patchy and
only to here and it was like see-through
it was very bad I wouldn't wear it down
ever without extensions in I mean I
would wear like hats a lot I'd put my
hair up in a messy bun I try to like
cover this parts of my skin it was
really really bad which is why actually
I felt I never felt more relevant than
when Will Smith hit Chris Rock because I
am a woman with alopecia I have done
stand up and I get how painful it is but
also you can't hit somebody right and I
wasn't surprised to see that because of
the whole words or violence thing
because if words are violence then
violence is an acceptable response to
violence and I will never understand how
this is being seen as a progressive
value because it's actually only as we
become more modern and civilized as
human beings that we say okay only words
to respond to words I mean you think
about it
for most of you in history even you know
Civil War it's like you said something
bad about my mom now we're gonna have a
shootout in the yard that's that's what
we used to do so I don't know why these
people like words or violence and I'm a
progressive it's like no you're behaving
like a neanderthal
um and I think there's such a difference
between expressing something that maybe
hurt your feelings
because you want to share that or you
want to share that you were hurt and
trying to use hurt feelings to place
yourself in a power position over others
and the latter is definitely what words
or violence is all about because as soon
as you've said that what that other
person did was violent the fact that
you're just keeping it at verbal only is
you doing them a favor right and they
don't think violence is violence because
they'll tell you words are violence but
then they'll tell you burning down a Pep
Boys isn't violence well ask the guy
who's in the bathroom at Pep Boys let me
ask something else because you said
you're a Libertarian and you're
obviously on Fox which is mostly
conservative and I always tell my
audience conservative is a very wide
thing right now if a gay married guy
with two kids whose pro-choice can be
thought of as a conservative then okay
fine that thing's that thing's pretty
wide but is it weird to you as like you
know a relatively young chick in New
York City that the progressives are the
miserable ones also like you I know you
don't really care about someone's sexual
preference or what they wear or what
they smoke obviously that's all the
libertarian stuff but that used to jive
with the progressives where I'm guessing
when you do a show now it's all
conservatives who maybe want a little
more government than you do or maybe
certainly on the religion side but those
are the ones that support you
yeah it's very very interesting because
I'm never gonna fit in anywhere just
because of you know I just don't and I
always vote third party I always have I
am you know and and I'm not gonna lie I
mean I'll say things on Fox that are
more libertarian I'm more liberal and
you know social issues I'm very Live and
Let Live for example and they'll say
something to me but then there is people
on the left who won't listen to me say
anything and they'll just say oh she
works at Fox News I know everything I
need to know about her and she's
disgusting and like I even had to you
know cut off contact with one of my
closest friends
um who I knew since I was a teenager
because it be you know after Trump
became president My Views never change
I'd already actually been working here
but the fact that I for example had Joe
Jorgensen the libertarian candidate for
president on my comedy advice show
sincerely cat was a huge issue for him
he was like you're you're no you're not
this is is this really good to be doing
right now is this and then they bring
words like safety and this and that into
it and it's like what if I work at Fox
News but I'm also my own person with my
own values and I'll have any
conversation you want I'm not scared I
think conversation's good I mean that's
my whole thing right but to just say I
know who you are because of where you
work and it's like don't you work at a
bank like some of these people it's like
right like Fox News there's actually are
people who aren't it's not all
Republicans here obviously it's a it's
right leaning right everybody knows that
but you don't know everything that there
is to know about me just from where I
work so I think it's the people on the
right they might be like oh I don't like
that you know I disagree with you or
whatever but
they will at least acknowledge me as an
individual with different views whether
as people on the left will have to be
like you work there therefore I don't
want to associate with you how shocking
has that been to you because obviously I
mean I feel the same way if you would
have told me of 10 years ago Dave you're
going to be on Fox basically every day
and you're gonna be friends with all of
these crazy right Wingers I would have
been like what are you talking about but
I find them open and fun and decent and
that's why I don't have a problem when
people say I'm a conservative because
it's like well conservative basically
just means kind of roughly Sane I'm with
you probably on all the libertarian
stuff but it's just kind of yeah you're
you believe in reality how about that
yeah it's it's been shocking I mean I
underst I'm hoping that this book can be
um something that brings people together
because I really do believe that we all
agree on a lot more of this stuff than
people want to admit for whatever reason
um but it's definitely been shocking to
me especially when it's been people in
my personal life who have known me for
all these years and they acknowledge
that My Views haven't changed I haven't
changed as a person I believe the same
things that I've always believed I I've
never said anything other than what I
believe but it's just the fact that I
work out at Fox and I think that I'm all
about into you know the individual the
autonomy of an individual to make their
own decisions but I also just think that
individuals there's so many different
kinds of people out there and
everybody's a unique individual and I
think that a lot of our problems come
from not speaking with people with whom
not just we disagree but that we think
we might disagree with which we might
not even disagree the way that we think
we do if we just expressed ourselves
more yeah I can tell you from where I
said it's just getting harder to do
because they won't talk to us I mean I
think it's what you're saying about okay
you're affiliated with Fox so a certain
amount of people think this and then you
know I just went to DC a couple weeks
ago every Republican we reached out to
16 said yes zero Democrats and it's like
that's that's a tough bridge to to
divide but but that's a little bit of
the inmates running the Asylum over
there right like they're afraid of their
own people even if they would be willing
to sit down with a scary interviewer
like me
yeah and I do have friends in my life
that are definitely uh left-wing
um some Democrats I honestly can have a
better conversation with someone who's
super super super Progressive because at
least they see a lot of the same flaws
in the system as I do they have the
exact opposite solution for which might
you know they just want the government I
want no government they want all
government so they hate the government
government should be bigger
yeah exactly so they see the problems
but it's the fact that the government so
but I can at least have a more open
conversation but those are people
obviously that I've known a long time
and they know me first before they kind
of know where I work but yeah it's been
difficult trying to people will think
that you know if they haven't met me
that they'll see where I work and
they're like oh okay well I know who
this is I already know who this is
because of where she works and it's like
that's actually not true if you just
spend five minutes with me you'd realize
that that isn't the case but you won't
spend five minutes with me and then you
unders then maybe you'll say oh it's
horrible how nobody gets along it's like
well come on like I'm actually I'm
actually trying I'm always open to a
conversation with anyone
let me ask you a couple things about the
Gutfeld exclamation point program over
there I'm pretty sure that Tyrus wants
to kill me what's going on over there no
I don't think so I think that guy hates
me and he's always looking at me like
he's about to get up and step on me
can you give me anything you don't think
so no I don't I don't think so I think
he said something about his pant leg and
then he called you out for it but I mean
he's not like
he already told you that you know what I
mean he's always going to let you know
how he feels we did also get into a very
drunken fight a couple years ago were
you there at that at the hotel bar Greg
was there a lot of wine and something
about race and it got very heated no I
wasn't we'll take that one offline okay
scratch that
um so one of the things that I always
tell people when I when I come back from
doing Gutfeld and it's just always great
every time it's like light and fun and
like it's just a joy to do is that it's
such a slim staff over there it's like I
feel like five people maybe including
the the janitor are working on that show
and how that is in such contrast to the
other late night shows that have these
massive staffs and everything else but
that's really how it is right there
right like you guys get in there in the
morning do you help him with the writing
at all yeah yes I do
um I nobody on the staff has just one
job I mean I write for the show
um I'm on the show every day
um same with like you know Greg's
assistant but she also is a like doing
production and it's it's there's nobody
on the show who has just one job our
entire staff is smaller than just the
writing staff of Stephen Colbert or
someone somebody like that
um I think we have two three maybe
people who just write but also they
sometimes are on the panel so I that's
actually not even true
um I've been obviously you know I I
write usually a segment every single day
and submit the guest intros which is
also funny because a lot of the ones
that he's gotten yelled at for being too
mean to me I wrote them so they're like
don't be mean to cat I'm like am I too
mean to cat because I wrote that do you
ever feel like you're gonna get him in
trouble as you're writing something and
you're like uh oh
yeah I have I have but it's again I
think a lot of it is I mean I think it's
because I'm a woman too I don't think
anybody would be like oh you're too mean
to kill me right I think it's just
because I'm a woman but I think that's
what I think is so great is I'm treated
as an equal I mean it's not like I can't
handle it just because I'm a woman I can
handle it and I can give it right back
and I have been for I don't know what
nine years now almost
so
um I I love it I think it's it's the
best I think being in that environment
where it goes back to intention right
and I write a chapter about this too
what matters is the intention and
there's this very harmful idea out there
right now that it's not the intention it
doesn't matter if someone's offended
that's all that matters but how can that
be true like how can that be true that
it's exactly the same if somebody makes
a joke
unintentionally somebody gets offended
by the joke then if somebody was
purposely trying to say something racist
or sexist and hurt somebody of course
that matters of course that makes a
difference and uh it's just absurd that
you know when it comes to like if you
kill someone on accident versus
purposely there's different designations
for that in our criminal code jokes are
a little less consequential than
someone's life so why are we treating it
like this I don't think anyone can
actually feel that way of course it
matters I mean when I was losing my hair
I made jokes about it all the time I
mean Greg even made a joke that I look
like Tanner from Bad News Bears without
my extensions in I laughed I thought
that was great it was funny I had an
ex-boyfriend who was abusive and would
tell me like you you know you you
rapidly aging idiot like how those
things aren't they're different someone
was trying to make me feel bad about
myself so we could continue to maintain
control over me how is that not
different than somebody who is just
trying to make me laugh of course it is
and it's just insane I mean all the
jokes the times that I've gotten I mean
I've been involved in a few different
scandals one with Kimmel over jokes that
was by accident I was talking about
something else and I accidentally said
something if I didn't mean to be
offensive but I was treated as if I did
it on purpose and not only is that not
fair to people making the joke that
really doesn't
reserve the absolute
shaming that we should be doing of
people who are trying to be jerks on
purpose right well also with a guy like
Jimmy Kimmel who's been in blackface
multiple times uh and you know making
fun of the quote-unquote black accent
from Carl Malone it's like that's why
he's going after someone like you for a
joke because he has to you know bow to
them forever otherwise they'll take him
out
well I sent him a book
um probably the most embarrassing thing
that happened to me on air was when I
made a joke about how hard it is to give
my cat uh a feral cat medication versus
a human and it was during a segment
about how his his what his Hiatus was
but we were actually also live and I
think this is the last time we were
alive actually
um because I was talking about how it's
super difficult and like the cat can
claw you or whatever and then Greg was
like oh like cat you know like Jimmy
Kimmel's son is like a heart issue and I
like didn't realize that yeah uh I get
that first of all I get the Fallon and
Kimmel confused and I now I was like oh
wait I do remember but I remember in the
article it was like my whole family's
healthy I remember before I made the
joke it was like just so I'm not gonna
get into I was like I'm not gonna get in
trouble but also with so much of Comedy
is like swinging and missing yeah you
know you don't really know if
something's gonna land until you try it
and I was just doing that you and you
can't make people too afraid to try or
else we're gonna miss out on some really
great jokes not just in terms of
laughter but some of the darker subjects
X that can have those healing powers but
I apologize because I genuinely did feel
bad I was like I didn't mean it like
that I don't want anybody to you know
think I did everyone who watched the
show was actually telling me like you
were fine like because I was holding
back tears the entire time I felt so
awful the next day somebody posted a
little tiny clip of it on Twitter and
said that I had been making fun of him
his family because his son had a heart
problem and that it was harder to have a
cat with a heart problem than a child
with a heart problem and different like
media Outlets like raw story if you can
call that took it and ran with it so I
was ironically at the vet with my cat
and I was like my
blowing up on social media people
telling me like you Jimmy Kimmel's
sister told me off and die all of
this stuff and like if I had actually
said it's actually no big deal your
kid with a heart problem because he has
a heart problem I would have deserved
that but I was trying to make a funny
joke about that and also about
people who don't have children like me
sometimes like having a child can be a
catch-all excuse for everything and if
you don't have a kid like something
that's relatable to cat owners something
that's relatable to people that don't
have children that's what I was trying
to do and I don't think I should be
treated the same way as if I was trying
to do that which is a totally I mean
that's just abhorrent right but it's
that wasn't my intention and again if we
make people too afraid to try
then we're going to lose out on so much
healing within ourselves and also with
one another through shared experiences I
often quote Oscar Wilde or at least
Loosely quote him I mean if you want to
tell people the truth you better be
funny or they're going to punch you in
the face so it's something like that let
me ask you a couple other things just
kind of world related stuff as people
can see out your window there I think
you're at the Fox News offices yeah um
you are in Midtown New York City a city
that I once lived in and loved for 20
years of my life but every time I go
back there which is pretty much only to
do Gutfeld at this point I find it to be
a zombie of a city it's not the same New
York Midtown where you are there's no
business people anymore everyone kind of
wearing a hood looks like they're going
to get weed or sell weed or steal weed
or something like what is going on in
New York
see I wouldn't even mind it being seedy
if it was less expensive because
a lot of things that made New York so
special too like the little small
businesses immigrant-owned restaurants
those you know special Little Gems a lot
of them are gone because they couldn't
survive being illegal in the pandemic
and everything is so expensive I mean
it's it's so crazy I mean I've been
thinking about maybe having one of those
baby things myself with my husband but
we're like where would we put it where
you know we have no taxes you know we
have no taxes on baby related stuff here
in Florida Florida I say it to you every
time I see you Florida I think I'm just
I I know and I would it's just this job
I am like less concerned with being
mugged on the street than I am knowing
for a fact I'm being gonna you know I am
being mugged by the government they take
so much of my income and I walk outside
and I'm like where what is this for
where did you you stole my money and
then what did you spend it on
and it's so expensive to live here it's
just ridiculous yeah it's I mean do you
find anyone there that thinks that it's
going well I mean I I still I know a few
remaining people in New York and
everyone I kid you not I think literally
everyone right now is in the process of
leaving like and and I already know
probably 20 people that left in the last
three years we would I mean my husband's
from New York my life dream was always
to live in New York I mean at this point
it's just I mean I'm also you know I'm
I've grown up a little bit I'm you know
married I'm not really going out a lot
uh and I'm just you know I'm working a
lot so I'm at home a lot and it's just
like my home's not that big when I say
home I mean handful of rooms that I'm
paying so much money for that I don't
even own I'm just renting and yeah I
don't know I mean I feel like also a lot
of this commercial real estate I mean a
lot of people are working from home a
lot of the you know the government the
state government your city government is
funded on this stuff often if that when
that goes away I mean you you pointed it
out too all the for lease signs a lot of
people aren't like I want to take on
this really expensive lease in this
place that's sort of looks like it's
collapsing uh so I think it's gonna get
worse actually yeah you know it's funny
uh you must know Douglas Murray who's a
Fox News contributor and so uh last time
I did Gutfeld and I saw you at the show
I went out to dinner with uh Douglas
after and he's in from London now living
in New York City and he kept telling me
how magical it was there and I kept
thinking man if you only knew what it
used to be like but you're seeing the
vestiges of magical but I guess that
could still be magical if you're from
somewhere else
yeah yeah I love Douglas Murray we're
sat next to each other at the White
House correspondence dinner he is a he
is a good one
um what else is on your mind politically
at the moment I mean obviously we can do
the woke stuff till we're like blue in
the face but what about the sort of
divide that's now happening between the
red and the blue I assume as a
Libertarian you're cool with this uh
Resurgence of federalism
yeah
right I mean okay as I mentioned before
uh talking about feelings I think is
actually a good thing I I know that a
lot of the refrain when it comes to
people on the right I mean you included
is that you know facts don't care about
your feelings and I totally get that but
it's also true that sometimes feelings
don't care about your facts and I know
that it's the only explanation for every
relationship I had in my 20s where I was
like but I but I love him like he treats
you horrible he has no job he's mean to
you he's cheating on you I was like but
I love him so like humans are emotional
creatures we are gonna have emotions and
as someone who's pro-free speech I think
that includes speech about feelings so I
think that that's something that the
right should acknowledge more and again
bring up that distinction between why
you're sharing your feelings there's a
difference between sharing your feelings
to try to express yourself to another
person or hey man that hurt me or hey
man have you ever seen it this way and
let's have a conversation and you hurt
me and now I have power over you and
anything you say against me if you argue
with me that's just further proof that
you're a sexist or a racist or a
homophobe or a transphob or whatever and
those two things I think that what we're
really missing is communication and I
think the more we're open to that the
more we can all get along and the more
that
thinks the more speech the better in
terms of bringing us together
um I think
a lot of the issues
are are a lot of the people who say that
they're sensitive and tolerant they're
really not because they kind of want to
catch somebody saying something bad
because there's nothing more powerful
than being a victim
and I hate to see that getting lumped in
with people who do just want to share
their feelings which I think is is a
good thing because we all have them I'm
a very sensitive emotional person but
there's a difference between that and
being somebody who expects their
feelings to be what the rest of the
world around you caters to that's
narcissistic that's selfish and if you
act out on other people and try to get
someone fired or like that's bullying
that's not being sensitive that's being
an and that's a very very
important distinction in my mind yeah
um to go to where we started for a
second uh you mentioned you're not
religious up top is that kind of the
number one thing that would sort of keep
you from saying that you're a
conservative because I mean from where
I'm at at least in the Florida version
of it like it is libertarian down here
like nobody really cares about weed down
here nobody cares who you marry down
here like people have their own personal
views and DeSantis obviously has his own
views on abortion and whatever but like
it's pretty much working down here where
it is more libertarian that is the the
sort of Freedom version of it down here
even less government than the
Republicans do that's my issue like I
really do believe taxation is theft um
when it you know when it comes to
immigration I never wanted the wall I
think that anybody who wants to come
contribute to our immigration is another
one I think that anybody who wants to
come contribute to our economy
who's non-violent should be more than
welcome to do so I don't believe in the
welfare state though like I don't
believe in I think that taking for
anybody really
um in a nut the main issue that I used
to have big get into fights with
conservatives about which I haven't
changed but Republicans have is foreign
policy I'm very non-interventionist on
foreign policy and a lot I've always had
the same views on it and I used to get
yelled at from Republicans about it and
now I get yelled at from Democrats about
it right the Tucker Wing the Tucker Wing
right they've moved to you and now the
Democrats are the Republicans of 20
years ago yeah I think I'm just very I I
I I can't with any of the idol worship
of any politician I want even smaller
government than Republicans do
definitely than Democrats do I'm I
wanted to criminalize all drugs I wanted
to criminalize sex work
um and and the religious thing I mean I
I don't think that religion should play
a role in the government but yeah I'm
not religious that is something that
people have an issue I mean people have
an issue with sometimes who are
conservative uh I don't mind it if
someone's like oh I'll pray for you like
that's fine but if people are like
you're a jerk it's like no I'm not like
I actually
I don't judge or think religious people
are bad people I'm I'm jealous which is
I know a sin also of people who are
religious because I think I'd be way
happier if I thought
that I you know and I'm agnostic I'm not
an atheist I just don't know I if I
didn't think that I'm just life is I'm
just gonna keep getting older and older
and older until I'm like decrepit and
I'm you know unattractive and you know
then I die and it's like just like
before I was born I hate that it's like
I don't I don't want it to be that way
but um yeah I think it's a lot of the
socials I think they're working on a
pill for that don't worry
yeah I'm in general like just I want
smaller government than the two-party
system does and I think that the
two-party system
kind of sometimes you know can play us
against each other a lot
and
to get away with its own corruption
because if everything's so polarized and
you're always gonna have your own side
defending you no matter what you do and
that really can just breed corruption
yeah it's interesting because I'm
philosophically I'm with you on most of
that you know the one though that I've
shifted a little bit probably in the
other way than you I think is
decriminalization of all drugs because I
used to be for a total decriminalization
and it's like if you look at San
Francisco where de facto it is right
like it's not legal to be selling
fentanyl but in in essence it is because
the cops don't do anything it's like
look at that place that can't be totally
disconnected from just like an endless
drug parade you know I yeah I think
actually when it comes to um drugs or
even New York City with weed right like
it the whole city part of the Decay and
I hate I I'm not against weed a hundred
percent I'm not against weed but like in
New York City the whole city smells like
weed now all the time and everyone's
stoned
I'm not stoned
um I think legally all right we found
one person yeah legalization worse on
the new criminalization where you can
actually
um because the system is still in place
um where it's like this Loop of like you
get into drugs and then how are you
gonna make money you can't make money
you know once you have this felony on
your record and all those sorts of
things where you can know where you were
buying where you could like just get
heroin if you wanted heroin if that
happened tomorrow I still wouldn't do
heroin like the reason that I don't do
heroin isn't because oh I it's illegal
it's because oh I'm not smoking crack
because I haven't seen that work out
well for anybody even if I could buy
crack at the store except for
right I think that right well I think
that your life is it's all your choice
but then it's also your responsibility
which is the other the other side of
that coin
um I think every every individual can
make the decisions for what works best
for themselves but then they're also
responsible for their own consequences I
think that it's just immoral to take
away someone's freedom because of
something that they've decided to put in
their body
tat timpf the book is you can't joke
about that I should have showed it at
the beginning we got it we made it
happen you know I'm not a I'm not a
cable news host over here you know
you're doing great I'm doing all right
Kat it was good seeing you I'll see you
in New York we can wander around catch
the wafting smoke of weed see if you
want to buy some heroin Etc et cetera no
no heroin for me I know heroin okay see
ya thank you if you're looking for more
enlightening and maybe even humorous
conversations check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell